i think a little bit of a review is in
order now and maybe just taking a a
little bit of step back to say well why
does a company even raise equity and why
do the people who who buy the equity
even do it in the first place
so the whole idea of what we're doing in
the last several videos is that a
company wants to raise money
it wants to raise
money to
you know start a website or build a
factory or do whatever else kind of
invest in the world in its kind of
productive capacity so it can build the
things that the company is meant to
build and in every example so far you
know we have the example where you know
me and my buddies
we have just a business plan unless
that's the asset and then you know we
own all the equity where the board of
the directors initially so that's all
the equity
so let's call this the
let me call this the
assets right now this is the equity
and we could go to a venture capitalist
it could have been an angel investor it
could have been you know we did we
talked about series a series b all of
that
and we could say okay you know we need
to raise x million dollars
what percentage of your company are do
we have to give away for that we'll say
okay well
we'll value what you have right now i'll
do a different number than what i did in
the past we'll value what you have right
now is one million dollars
and so
if you need another two million dollars
so let's say there's we value what you
have right now is one million dollars
let's say right now you have
one million shares
right so the company's pre-money
valuation is a million so they're
essentially saying
that the company right now is worth a
dollar per share there's a million
dollars worth of assets and there's a
million shares so a million divided by a
million is a dollar per share so they're
valuing it at
one dollar per share
and essentially they're saying that
we're willing to give you or we're
willing to buy more shares from you at a
dollar so if we give you
let me see let me do green i'll do a
different color i'll do purple
will give you
draw the box
will give you
i don't know
two million dollars
we'll give you two million dollars
and since we're buying it at a dollar
per share we get two million shares for
that
two million shares for that so this two
million shares now all of this is the
equity
right
this is what the founders had this is
all the equity
and so now there is
the company has the
what we say is worth a million dollars
and this is kind of an arbitrary thing
and we'll talk more about how you can
actually value these intangible assets
and things but now they had that and now
they have another two million dollars so
the post-money valuation pre-money was
one million post money is now two
million and now we had one million
shares now we have three million shares
so essentially for giving two million
dollars
these venture capitalists or whoever so
these shares go to some vc or angel
investor
they have now two-thirds of the company
they have two out of three million
shares or 66 of the company for giving
the two million dollars so that was kind
of a private raise of capital and so
you've probably heard the words private
company and public company
a private company is one whose shares
are not traded on a public exchange so
if this company wants to
raise money by selling equity the only
place that can do it is to venture
capitalists or to private equity firms
and we'll talk a little bit more about
kind of the difference a venture
capitalist really is a private equity
firm because it's buying private equity
but private equity tends to
invest in more established business when
people just talk about private equity by
itself but we'll go we'll do several
videos on that so this is essentially
this company is a private company
raising private equity now the example
we did in the last video
is you know let's say this company grows
to a certain size let me just do another
company so
it's clean
let's say i have another company these
are its assets
and this is its let me draw its current
equity base
right there
they should be the same size but i think
you get the idea hey you know these
assets it could be you know has some
cash
it has some factories or land it could
have a bunch of stuff it could have some
technology or we could have some
intellectual property
you know maybe it's a drug company or
maybe it's a technology company has a
bunch of patents and stuff and then it
has some intangibles you know a brand
who knows what it has these are the
assets of the firm this is the equity of
the firm so this company right now has
no debt and we'll talk about that in a
second what it means to have debt
right
and this is his current shareholder base
maybe some of these are you know some
vcs who invested in the company when it
was private there's you know maybe the
founder has these shares but this is the
equity base right here
and let's say
this company wants to raise a lot of
money and this is kind of a review of
the last video it can do an initial
public offering so right now it's
private right all of the all of these
shares right now that are owned by the
vcs and the and the the initial founders
of the company they're not traded on a
public exchange this vc can't go to the
nasdaq and sell their shares they can't
you know go to their broker and say hey
sell my million shares i have in company
x they have to just sit on them maybe
they can find another private uh equity
investor to buy their shares or you know
and you know maybe these founders
there's no liquidity here there's no
other person they can sell the shares to
and also if this company wants to raise
money right now it has to kind of go to
a vc and do a very kind of
you know do the whole process where you
negotiate what this value is what the
pre-money value is and they have to come
up with all these legal documents and
all of these
all of these stipulations around you
know we'll give you this money but if
this happens then you have to give us
this interest rate and if you know all
these type of things
so what they might say we need to raise
a lot of money we want all of these guys
want a way for them to be able to sell
their shares easily if they need to and
this company says well we need to raise
you know a ton of money let's say we
want to raise 100 million dollars and we
can't that's hard to raise from just any
one individual investor even if they are
a big institution so they'll do an
initial public offering and that really
just means and you know the ipo and this
is a review of the last one is that for
the first time this company is going to
register its shares it's going to
register its shares with the sec
and it's going to because it does that
it's going and it's going to list its
shares on an exchange it'll get a ticker
symbol you know it'll maybe be company
you know this will be its ticker symbol
t i ck or the last k in the last video
could be socks because it's going to
sell socks and then people can trade
these shares on that exchange you know
it could be on the on the nasdaq or
something and i think some of you all
have had experience doing that where you
know you go on your charles schwab
account and you you say i'm going to
sell sock well that that company that
you're selling is at some point did
initial public offering and got and
registered with the sec and got listed
on exchange and the the way it really
works is
it's it's fundamentally the same as when
you raise money from a vc but now
instead of let's say
instead of raising money from a vc all
of the money comes from
essentially the public right
it goes through these banks and
brokerages but it's coming from a bunch
of you know small i'm just divvying it
up right here you know it could be
coming from millions and millions of
people but the same process kind of
holds in order to to see what price
these shares are bought at someone has
to say well what is the company worth
before it gets the money
what is the company worth before it gets
this money kind of a pre-money valuation
that still has to happen and that's what
the investment bank does the investment
bank will essentially do a model and say
oh you know this is worth the company
beforehand was worth 50 million dollars
and it's it's kind of a you know they'll
kind of go out into the market and say
well you know and let's say the company
right now has i don't know let's say the
company already has i'll make a number
five million shares right
so that this piece right here is five
million so if the if the banks value the
company at fifty million it has five
million shares they'll say okay right
now the pre-money valuation is ten
dollars a share
and the bank will go out there and
they'll kind of gauge interest and say
well you know does it seem like the
market's willing to pay ten dollars a
share for a company like this or give
this company a 50 million
pre-money valuation and if so they'll
move forward with the value with the uh
with the ipo and hopefully they'll they
actually hopefully the market actually
wants to not pay ten dollars per share
the market maybe wants to pay twenty
dollars a share so all of these guys
essentially let's say they'll they'll
pay ten dollars a share so let's say
that they raise
they sell ten million shares
at ten dollars a share so the company is
able to raise a hundred million dollars
right ten times ten hundred million
dollars
that it can do to make you know big ads
and all of that
and what what the bank hopes is by
selling these shares at ten dollars a
share so let's say this is the
this is days
and this is price
let me change colors so what the
investment bank wants to hope is that on
day one you sell it ten dollars a share
and then the price moves up that the
demand was actually to sell it for much
more and there's a bit of a balancing
act because if they sell it for too
little then the company won't get as
much money as it deserves but if they
sell it for too much and the stock price
goes down then you kind of have a stigma
associated with the ipo
but anyway this begs the question of
you know
sure i understand why the company is
selling shares it needs money it needs
to operate it needs to build factories
or put out advertising and all that but
why are people buying shares to begin
with why do people buy shares in the
stock market and frankly there's two
answers you know and one is kind of the
obvious one because they think the
shares will go up but to some degree
that's you know that's speculation if if
i'm buying a share at ten dollars just
because i'm hoping that there's some
other dude out there who maybe a few
weeks later is going to pay 15
i'm just speculating if you know i'm
just saying oh ipos go up so let me buy
it but but economically why was
why was this even worth ten dollars to
begin with
you know how do we even think about that
valuation at a very even high level why
is this even worth ten dollars a share
to begin with
and the idea is is that these assets
assets are nothing but claims on future
benefits right a house is an asset
because you get the future benefit of
getting to live in it right or the
future benefit of not having to pay rent
so the future benefit of these is
they'll hopefully at some point in the
future generate an income stream and
even more they'll generate cash and at
some point in the future and a lot of
companies don't do it right now they'll
actually dividend out that cash so
there's some there's a couple of things
that might like that that will make this
equity have kind of an economic it'll
it'll ground it economically and it
could be these assets starting to pump
out cash and then each of the
shareholders
will get a dividend right a dividend is
just cash that's given to the
shareholders so let's say that this is a
stock certificate in sock
so at some point when this when this
when the assets of this company start
generating cash each of the shareholders
might be getting a dividend
or maybe a large company at some future
date says wow you know this is an
awesome technology it'll complement what
we already have and maybe they'll buy
out the company maybe they'll pay um
maybe they'll pay 300 million dollars
for this for this company and then you
know essentially they're paying 300
million dollars it was it and there's
what 15 million shares so they're paying
20 a share so those are the economic
kind of grounding points that why these
shares even have a value and i'll i'll
go a lot into a lot more detail i'll
make a whole playlist on how you how do
you even think about whether this is
worth
50 million or is it worth 5 million or
is it worth 500 million and it's kind of
an art more than a science because you
can make
you're going to make tons of assumptions
in terms of how fast the company grows
what's the risk-free rate of return that
you could get on other assets you know
essentially where else you could you put
your money um when does the company
dividend out its money you know there's
so many assumptions so it's more of an
art so it's really kind of you try to
get a handle on things
but there's no real right answer the
real right answer is kind of what
someone's willing to pay for it
but anyway i'll see you in the next
video